he won an Oscar nomination for Stand and
Deliver
and just made a terrific directorial
debut an American made she was a star
Splash Blade Runner and Roxanne ladies
and gentlemen daryl hannah and edward
james olmos
our categories achievement and sound and
of all the areas of filmmaking perhaps
the greatest strides have been made here
you can't go much further than from
complete silence in the early days to
the remarkable multi-channel
multi-speaker setups found today in
almost all movie houses the men and
women who are in charge of the sound for
film must balance the music dialogue and
sound effects in a simple seamless track
here are five groups of sound
specialists who have done outstanding
work this year
Gary summers Randi Tom Gary Rydstrom and
Glenn Williams for backdraft Jerry
Porter Mel mid-calf David Jay Hudson and
doc came for Beauty and the Beast
Michael Minkler and Greg land Edgar Todd
a Maitland for JFK
Tom Fleischmann Christopher Newman for
the Silence of the Lambs Tom Johnson
Perry rides from Eric summers and Lee
Orla for Terminator 2 Judgment Day
and the Oscar goes to
yes here goes to Tom Johnson Gary rights
from Gary summers and Lee or LA for
Terminator 2 Judgment Day
well first of all we'd like to thank the
Academy Tristar pictures Carroll
co-productions director Jim Cameron and
the people at Lightstorm entertainment
BJ ract Stephanie Austin and Pam Easley
of t2 productions Gloria borders the
supervising sound editor who put
together the finest crew of sound
editors and assistants on the planet Tom
Kobayashi and Kate Coombs at Skywalker
Sound North with its superb machine room
crews engineering and post-production
support staff we'd also like to thank
our parents wives children and friends
who have supported us over the years in
a very demanding and unpredictable
business like the one we're in thank you
very much